michelle how many years did you think
and dream about the edgemar acting
studio before it came
a reality
i think since i was a child
i remember when i was 10 years old i
literally opened a little acting camp i
grew up in paris
in france and i
created in my basement
a camp all day where we would was
basically an acting camp where kids
did all kinds of creative games and
improvisations and i made them lunch
and i always
for sure dreamed of
creating a cultural art center
where all the disciplines would be under
one roof
and then fast forward how long did that
actually take to become a reality well i
walked in here i'd love to tell that
story because it was
certainly a big defining moment in my
life and in the history of this theater
when i snuck in here illegally in the
middle of the night in the year 2000 in
the main space
main theater and looked up with my
little flashlight thinking i'd be
arrested any moment
and you know really feeling a certain
energy in the place
where i saw literally you know
productions happening audience coming
lights
and i knew nothing about what it would
take i was in complete complete denial i
thought i would sew curtains and buy
flats and put them up myself i was just
beyond in denial because what it took to
build this to you know theater complex
in capital campaign in the year 2000 was
a million point three
so i forgot about curtains and flats
that was the least of my problems i had
to worry about drywall electricity
plumbing and so i begged people to help
and i was lucky enough i have no idea
how i did it
but you know here we are we cut our
ribbon in 2002.
this is our
uh what is its 11th year anniversary
next year it'll be 12 years
and 12 years goes in a flash you blink
and it's and it's there but there's been
a lot of magic here in 12 years